[Music]
all right so we obviously
had to talk about this especially with
our man chappelle here
[Laughter]
everybody what are you going to bring
out we got to hear from what's happening
to
this week
everybody see that [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] crazy man oh but you know what's
funny though i just saw the photos of
the dude and what he looks like and his
arms like this he has a lump on his
chain
this [ __ ] right here
oh my god
look at this this will look like he's
bone breaking like about to start
dancing just [ __ ]
is that chapelle security like his
security took care of you
i think everybody there's like 30 dudes
yeah there was so many yeah amy fox and
like buster rhymes everybody
they were all there too yeah so they all
jumped his house oh did you see that all
started jumping huh yeah that's what i
said start study jump dog there's a
funny ass tweet that was like who's the
security guard batman
how are you gonna get handcuffed with a
broken arm bro the fact that they still
handcuffed him with that arm it's like
bro at least get my good on
do you want to do this one
well dude even if you didn't handcuff
him he's not going anywhere yeah it's
like
you think i'm gonna yank
so so the man who attacked dave
chappelle um on stage is actually
charged with assault with a deadly
weapon did he have a gun on him it was a
gun that shoots knives
i think it's a i think it's a is that a
joke is that a gag but the handle looks
like a gun it looks like a revolver
right it says oh it's not a gun no it's
not a gun i heard it was a knife but
there was something up yeah oh so if it
it just opens it's like a prank it looks
like it looks like a prank knife because
i read it was um he was armed with a gun
and a knife
so i was like i think that's what that
is that's the picture of it then you're
like oh it just folds into the gun
you're like a little final fantasy what
the [ __ ] what a nerd
is that a cloud stripe
what got that [ __ ] out of [ __ ] oz
dude like a hot topic knife
the world's worst [ __ ] spy shop ever
it's like oh [ __ ] that's a threat oh
wait oh okay
so uh the man who attacked dave
chappelle on stage during a stand-up has
been charged with assault with a deadly
weapon uh chappelle was performing at
the hollywood bowl in l.a on tuesday may
3rd as part of a netflix is a joke the
festival
and as the show was ending he was
attacked by a 23 year old man who has
since been named isaiah isaiah lee by
the lapd
so what's his rapper name though because
he's a wrap he's around oh he's a rapper
yeah he wrote it he thought i was being
drunk
he wrote a song about dave travel or
something yeah
no [ __ ] like a diss track i don't know
it's a diss track i need to look this up
now hold on you're considered a hate
crime then like he's been hating dave
chappelle i don't know oh is it a love
crime track dude oh though because you
know is it because he loved him so much
he wanted to tackle him with the hug
he considered a promotional move as well
imagine he's [ __ ] chucking his cd i
know he's like hip hop you like hip hop
i got the fire i got the fire
that's all it was that's all it was
you liked him he should have just put a
qr code like hip-hop yeah he's a big fan
you just put a huge r coat on his head
that's all you got to do
get a tattoo right here just let's get
it
and did this dude attend the show by
himself
did he do this because that guy for sure
went by himself yeah he went with a
bunch of people and then he didn't they
didn't know a knife
they don't have very many people around
them gun knife if somebody was with them
they're never going to own it for the
rest of their lives oh yeah
isaiah
a song about dave chappelle two years
before this recent attack so about
attacking him at the hollywood bowl two
years later wow imagine he's probably
he's just an order that's like that's
like early covet days huh yeah so he was
like why did he attack him what's it i
want to know
no motive yeah anyone said yeah they
don't know yet oh not sure but i think
dave made a joke he like totally doubled
down on the fact that he's getting a lot
of hate for you know like transphobia
type stuff and then i think he called
him a trans but he's like that must be a
trans man oh yeah yeah
really yeah and then chris rock comes on
and he's like was that will smith yeah
yeah we still bart's joke dude they did
still bars jokes
oh damn bart texted it to him
i was like that was my joke yeah yeah
he's all defeated now he's like
[ __ ] white people
that's a good one
and then uh will smith
[Laughter]
word for word that's it
will smith
you gotta have the three dots
you know you know it was really dope
though to see uh in like the aftermath
footage and stuff um when jamie foxx was
there and then uh dave was you know dave
was playing it off like really
professional he was yeah he was pissed
and he was saying stuff but at the same
time he's like yo
james fox here come here jamie foster
right he's like give it up for the fox
everybody and then james fox grabs mike
and he's literally saying like yo
everybody we need to take care of this
this man is a genius we all need to make
sure you know what i mean
when you hear people like talking about
dave as like the goat like that's just
so powerful another genius is talking
about
yeah look at chris rock being there in
the audience and coming up and making
the jokes like chris rock was also the
goat like back in his day you know but
for all of them to be able to praise one
guy and be like this dude's in jesus
name
is dave chappelle's not even 50 yet wow
is he really he's he's 48 wow but the
wisdom dude
yeah
you know i was uh i was at a diner the
other day and it was a table full of
like um
like old mexican folks right and they're
like talking about dave chappelle and
they're like you know i know he's
controversial and everything but like um
i don't agree with everything that he
says
but he's saying what we're all thinking
that's why everyone [ __ ] with you yeah
that's why
yeah because i'm like damn everyone
loves dave because i think like there's
just so many weird things that are
happening in media and like society that
no one wants to talk about yeah well no
one wants to talk because like if you
have an opinion about anything
like within i guess within more so
within recent you're just so scolded for
it and it's like you're the scum you're
like made to be like the scum of the
earth because you have a different
opinion
just asking a question and it's insane
that like
we live that way because there's a i
mean and it's like why
you know like it i mean
we all have social media we have all
this [ __ ] and you know we put all our
things out there online and it's open
for people to comment and say the things
that they say
you get you get great comments and you
get comments where people talk [ __ ] and
it's like well they're allowed to do
that yeah you know what i mean
part of the game if art is part of the
[ __ ] game but that's just what it is
like i don't get mad at those people who
are talking [ __ ] about me one they don't
know me i don't [ __ ] know the
[ __ ] no i didn't know they
existed but but but i mean hey whatever
like i mean okay that's what you said
but should we go like oh this person
should never work a day in their life
ever again yeah i'm not gonna i'm never
getting any jobs yeah i'm not gonna try
to go like deeper into their profile and
be like yo whatever job you work at i'm
[ __ ] you know let's cancel sending
this to your [ __ ] boss i don't care i
don't want a good that's exhausting yeah
now pre-anger management chapel
now listen i beat that [ __ ]
even that's more honorable i think like
if you don't like someone just challenge
them and [ __ ] fight and that to me is
more real than like that is real hiding
behind a noble warrior i love that
but what a lot of people do now is just
hide they have like fake accounts
they'll come and like try to ruin your
life they'll [ __ ] tell your bosses or
whatever you know they they try to make
these attacks on you and it's like if
you don't like someone find a way to
confront them well that's the best part
about dave chapel too because we all
like like we're talking about it's like
man all right i got some [ __ ] to say
all right i'm gonna let dave should fall
come up here and say
and then
so then now what i want to do what i
really want to do is i want to be like
hey anthony i'm about to [ __ ] i want to
[ __ ] you up real bad
i'm gonna let dave chappelle come do it
come on dude
and here he is everybody
here right now
but you know it is insane to just you
know
i mean [ __ ] it let a person say
something i mean there's probably people
that
[ __ ] hate every single one of us but
it's like all right
whatever i'm not gonna [ __ ] i don't
want to [ __ ]
defeat you in any way you know because
you're already a [ __ ] to me in my mind
time
you know already it's just a wild wild
world we live in when people are trying
to attack comedians like that for doing
their job yeah like they're supposed to
do social commentary they're supposed to
like poke fun at me
yeah i always explain it to people i was
like we're not up there to say the the
correct thing because then that doesn't
make a comment but it's like a [ __ ]
yo think about it you know what i'm
saying like the funny the funny part is
saying it in a twisted way
that most people would would think and
but also don't take it that serious but
isn't late night comedy killing it right
now
who's your favorite mom doesn't that
kind of disrupt everything you just said
because like kimmel's killing it and
[ __ ] colbert's killing it
i mean think about that last joke that
they just told like it was [ __ ] great
they make dad jokes seem edgy dude i
know
but it's but it's insane man because
that's the art of comedy is the fact
that you can
say
you know take this uh topic or whatever
the case may be
and what most people would think about
it you have this different perspective
of it and to be able to say it in a
funny way that's like the art of comedy
that's why comedy is so
hard you know because you your brain has
to think in a way where you really have
to step out this outside the box of what
majority people are thinking of a
situation yeah and look at it and go oh
that's funny or even step out of your
own box sometimes yeah yeah exactly you
might have your own personal beliefs but
for the sake of comedy you're trying to
expand your mind and try to change the
perspective on things but then i think
nowadays people have so much asperger's
they think that whatever you say is
exactly how you believe
rather than playing with concepts yeah
they tell you so literally well yeah
cause they're satire there's like you
know being just absurd there's like
different styles of comedy right and
sometimes you're playing a character
like you're playing the racist because
it's funny to laugh at racist not that
you actually believe in you because it's
right and you're saying these things
exactly yeah so i i do this joke i do
this joke about uh
because i was adopted into a white
family in my teens and i do this joke
and my adopted father was a little dude
and i do this joke about like beating
him up
but it didn't but it did not like i did
not beat him up right yeah and so i had
filmed this set and i did that joke
and uh
someone left a comment it was like oh my
god like these people gave you a second
chance at life
they're like they're like uh you you're
a toxic person for this
i can't believe you know you would do
that to you
you just admitted to assault
it's like
but the funny part is just that he's a
little dude and i was bigger than him
and i still am bigger than him and it
was bigger than him like at 16 years old
and it's just funny to think of a 16
year old beating up a guy that took him
in
you know to help him you know with life
that's that's the funny thing there's
still people watching this really like
that's not funny that's so that's how
scary i think the funniest thing that's
happening right now like i get the whole
like sensitive stuff about religion
politics all that stuff right but when
it comes to your own trauma yeah i'm
like this is my life
they don't give us the right to [ __ ]
joke about our own childhood like you
should never laugh about that you should
never joke about abuse and it's like
[ __ ] it's my story my story it
has nothing to do with you if i want to
be boring with your own family yeah yeah
exactly but now there's this whole idea
of like you have to
express yourself in one way like if
you're going through something the right
way yeah the right way they're like oh i
went through this traumatic time and now
this is how i feel and let's all cry
together and it's like but not everybody
not everybody thinks that way you know
like like comics cope a different way
saying and i tell people because i have
like such a crazy [ __ ] story and i go
i'm not sad
i'm not i'm not sad about my [ __ ] way
because it already happened was like we
want me to do that's how i think of it
like
there's really nothing i could do about
something that already [ __ ] happened
yeah yeah why would you joke about
trauma why would you [ __ ] yeah
you should never he just doubles it like
hey
like i just recently found out that my
mom i just recently found out that my
mom has cancer and i must have done so
many like i'm betting against my mom
jokes like
you know what i mean like like i was
like i live in vegas i can make money
off of this like if what's the line on
that yeah
how can i like how do i bet both sides
how do i win right or even like what's
the spread on this [ __ ] yeah side bends
so that's for that's for you to have
like that that's how i think of it like
you know when i talk about my life and
my adopted folks or any situation of me
because majority of my comedy is about
my life and how i grew up and just what
you know it's all about me so it's like
if you get offended about something of
my life well you can eat a dick
because it doesn't have anything to do
with you and i want to reply to these
people but it's like i would exhaust
myself oh yeah even no it's either
coffee cake you could eat a dick you
could eat it yeah i know yeah
i should i should have said i'll beat
your ass too
that's what i should have said
[Music]
you